- So I was thinking about
what to talk about tonight.
I usually cover current
events on my show
and I wanna briefly touch
on what's going on
in Virginia first,
which Rod just
referenced quickly.
Because I think today,
although I don't think
that most of the solutions
that we are gonna need
and hopefully we'll
find in this country
will be purely through politics
and certainly through
the political class
that we have right now.
I do think today
is an incredibly,
incredibly important moment
for the future of this country.
What's happening in
Virginia right now
is sort of a bellwether
for everything
that this conference
has been about.
If wokeism and leftism
and collectivism
is gonna continue
to be on the march,
it's gonna go through McAuliffe,
it's gonna go through Virginia.
And suddenly in
the last two weeks,
it feels like maybe
that isn't gonna happen.
And I try not to
spend too much time
on the self-imposed mental
institution that is Twitter,
but I was looking around
Twitter this morning
and you can sort of feel it.
You can sort of
feel people going,
man, the anti-woke people,
if we can get a win and it
doesn't even necessarily mean
that we love everything
about Youngkin.
It doesn't mean that we
agree with all his policies
or think he's the best
politician or any of that stuff
or that politicians are the
ones to fix it, as I said.
But if we can get a win
right now, just something,
that it might start
the turnaround.
I think we can all feel that,
we're finally all kind of
having enough of this, right?
We let it happen.
I referenced this last night,
it was like all of these
kids that were in college
with blue hair and genderless
and screaming at professors
and causing what was it,
Berkeley to spend
something like $400,000
to secure the campus
when very scary
4'7" Ben Shapiro showed up.
It's like, he's very small.
He's actually in my pocket.
You guys wanna see him?
There's a feeling though that
they've overstepped, right?
They've really overstepped
by coming for the kids.
First, we're gonna inject
the kids with the vaccine,
and it really doesn't
even matter what you think
about vaccines and
in a certain respect,
it doesn't even matter what
you think about mandates.
The fact that the FDA, I'm
sure many of you saw the video,
just a few days ago, the
FDA board was talking
about vaccine
mandates for children.
And one of the doctors
actually said on video,
"We don't know what it'll do,
that's why we have to
give it to the kids."
I mean, this is the
level of craziness
that we are dealing with, right?
They are using our
children as experiments.
They are putting people in masks
and locking people at home.
We know all of the endless
things that this is doing to us
psychologically and culturally.
I come from a place
called California.
Thank you. One person booing it.
The one other Californian
here, obviously,
where it's like living
in another country truly.
I mean, these last
couple days in Florida
where I've seen your faces,
people smile and
aren't afraid of you.
I mean, we've done something
so incredibly dangerous
and look how
quickly they did it.
Look how quickly they did it.
And that's why
last night I said,
you have to give the
devil his due here.
We can all run around and
say wokeism is ridiculous
and these people are buffoons
and they don't know what
they're talking about
and okay, fine, so be it,
they all seem like clowns,
but you kinda have
to admire it, right?
Look how much destruction
they have created
in really a couple years.
And I know we can talk
about sort of the long march
through the institutions
and this was all happening
in colleges 20 years ago.
I get it.
I talk to some of my
conservative friends now,
people that I thought were
very scary right-wingers
like Dennis Prager and
Larry Elder and Glenn Beck.
And I'll say something
and they'll go,
"Yeah, Dave, that's what
I was saying 30 years ago.
Thank you, appreciate that."
But just in the last couple
years, fueled by big tech,
this woke thing has
done so much disruption.
And that's why I really do think
that this election today in
Virginia is so important.
And it's funny because
I live in California.
Here we are in Florida.
It should probably have nothing
to do with any of us, right?
Unless any of you
here live in Virginia,
in which case I hope
you voted a couple times
before you got here.
Unless you do, it
really shouldn't
have anything to do with this.
I mean, the Federalist
system was set up
so that the states would be
separate and mostly independent
and the federal government
would do a little bit
to make sure we're
in essence not at war
and we're having
trade with each other
and things of that nature,
but suddenly it
feels very important.
It feels very important
that this Virginia race
go the right way,
because one of the things that
I talk about often on my show
is we need a little hope.
I toured with Jordan Peterson,
he would often talk about
that star in the distance.
He would reference "Pinocchio"
and "When You Wish Upon A Star".
And I think we've sort of lost
that in America right now,
we're all sort of
wandering around.
We wake up every morning,
you go online or
you watch the news,
you see the next
ridiculous thing
that these people
are throwing on us,
whether it's the gender stuff
or the vaccination stuff,
or now Joe Biden is
gonna solve climate.
I mean, the guy fell asleep
at the talk yesterday.
Did you see that?
Like, we are just
inundated with stupidity
and we need some hope.
So I think today
there is some hope
and I'll be talking
with Jonathan Isaac,
who you guys might know,
who's the Orlando Magic
basketball player,
who's come out against
vaccine mandates.
We just had a little talk.
I'm gonna talk to him, yeah.
(crowd clapping)
It's not an easy feat
for a guy like him.
Kyrie Irving is the one
that most people know,
he's a big star.
The guy's probably got 80
million bucks or something.
Jonathan Isaac's only been
in league for a couple years.
He has a huge, bright future
that he's put on the line,
but I don't know if
it's even public yet,
but I'll be interviewing
him tonight right up here
before J. D. Vance speaks,
and he's ready to step
into a wider world
and realize that I don't know
that he considers himself
a conservative or a Republican
or that he'd ever
thought he'd talk
at a conference like this,
but he was very
excited to come here
and we need that sort of thing.
We need more and more
people to realize
that the machine is
not gonna save us.
And again, great,
let's get Youngkin in.
Let's hopefully get a little
signal out to the system
that things can turn around,
but it's just not
the politicians that
are gonna save us.
It's us that is gonna save
us. That really is the truth.
(crowd clapping)
So I was thinking,
a lot of people know I
would say roughly my story.
I was a lefty, I
was a progressive.
And then there's a
moment that has been seen
probably 50 million times or
something like that on YouTube.
Where as a lefty, I sat
down with a conservative
or really libertarian talk
show host, Larry Elder,
who you all know.
And we started talking about
systemic racism and I said,
"Larry, but what about
systemic racism?"
And as a lefty,
I kind of just believed it
existed because I said it.
And that's really what they
believe about a lot of things.
You just say something
and well, I said it,
so it must be true.
And I'm sure most of
you have seen the clip,
but Larry really
just disassembled me.
He did it just beautifully
and sort of like operating.
He just had stats and numbers
and went through everything.
And I don't know how many
people can say that their best
and worst career moment
were at the exact same time.
But I really believe that
I can say that about myself
because it was my worst moment
for very obvious reasons.
I got into a debate not
ready, not armed with facts,
not ready to counter
the ideas of someone
who I really should have known
has been doing this for 30 years
and he wasn't just
gonna lay over
and just let me run across him.
But I think it was
my best moment also
because at the time
we were on Ora TV,
I had a big staff
in the control room
and we taped it and it was
gonna air the next day.
And I walked into
the control room
and the producers said to
me, "Dave, we'll cut that.
We'll cut that moment.
We're obviously not
gonna put that up."
And I don't know what was
going on in my head exactly,
but I thought, no, we
have to leave that.
That was the true moment.
If yeah...
(crowd clapping)
If there's any purpose
of being an interviewer
or trying to explain to
people what I believe
or listening to people
who know more than me,
then when something
true happens,
we certainly can't cut that.
And over the next couple days,
it got cut across YouTube
and all the usual headlines,
conservative destroys
libtard and the rest of it.
And I was like, oh God, what
a headache this is gonna be.
But within about 48 hours,
I started looking
at the comments,
which is not something I
recommend any sane person do,
but I was looking and
I saw a lot of people
were kind of like it seemed
like Rubin paid attention.
It seemed like he wanted to
continue the conversation.
And I really did.
And then I started
having conversations
with some of the people
that I referenced earlier,
like Shapiro and Prager and Beck
and all of these people.
And I realized that there
was a much wider world
and a world, which
I think sorta now
I can bring this into
why we're all here,
a world which we
have got to save.
I mean, we are handing it to
people who don't deserve it.
And we all know it, right?
We all know something
is very wrong
and no matter what
you think you have,
they want it and they
are coming for it.
There is no norm.
Look how different
the world is right now
as we stand here on
November 1st, 2021
than it was in February
of 2020, right?
I mean, basically we are in
a completely different world
in less than two years.
Remember, we used to
talk about things,
just two years ago,
less than two years ago,
we had never heard the phrase
two weeks to flatten the curve.
Now we don't hear it anymore
because they decided it was
useless, it wasn't needed.
We don't talk about
herd immunity.
They have just pushed
and pushed and pushed.
We have guys like Fauci up
there telling us to double-mask
while he's sending
emails to his friends,
telling them that
the masks don't work
and they actually could be worse
because you might
touch your face
or you'll adjust your mask more,
so you do touch your face more
and that's not gonna work.
And the litany, I don't have
to go into all of the things
that they have all said
that they don't do.
And Gavin Newsom
locking kids at home
while he's eating at French
Laundry and every other,
I mean, every single
Democrat politician on this.
The height of absurdity as
they flaunt their own rules
in our faces and
all of these things.
But look, the world is
very, very different.
And the purpose, I
think, of this conference
and why I wanted to come here,
even though it's perhaps a
little bit out of my main lane,
is that I don't really care
what our differences are,
I really don't.
I know that some of
us in this room, yeah.
(crowd clapping)
And I don't mean that
to be glib or something,
I mean that quite literally.
I know we have some political
differences in this room.
For those of you that
saw the panel last night,
we went through some
of those differences
and they are pretty
intense, right?
These are deeply held
religious and philosophical
and political positions
that we hold differently
than each other.
And that's important.
So I don't wanna be dismissive
of those important issues,
and we will have to deal
with all of those issues.
But I think that the purpose
of this conference is to go,
okay, we've got a bigger
problem at the moment.
The problem is that
the same old thing
that caused all of our ancestors
to come to this country,
pretty much everyone
in this room,
think about your ancestors.
Why did they come here?
Whether you're one
generation off,
whether you're first generation,
whether you're six
generations in,
everybody in
America, in essence,
with the exception
of Native Americans
and African Americans,
came here for a
better life by choice,
they came here often
with absolutely nothing.
We all know the story, right?
They came with the suitcase,
the clothes they had on the
back, all of that stuff.
We have done an experiment that
is so profoundly impactful.
It's so incredible that
we almost can't understand
that it happened.
We can't understand
how much better,
I really believe this,
how much better our
ancestors were than us,
because I don't think
that most of our ancestors
would be sitting around
letting this happen.
My two grandfathers who
fought in World War II,
I'm pretty sure they
wouldn't be sitting around.
I don't know exactly
what they would be doing,
but I don't think they
would be sitting around
letting this happen.
And we're all letting it
move on us and move on us.
And that's why when
I say whatever our
differences might be,
and again, not to diminish them,
they are deep, they are deep.
But if you would like
to save this thing,
if you think that
America is worth saving,
we have half the country
seemingly at the moment
that does not think that
this experiment was good.
And the irony, of course,
is they never leave, right?
They always tell you
they're gonna leave.
They always tell us...
It's like, leave. I'll
buy Lena Dunham a ticket.
Go, go already.
Let's get someone like
Chelsea Handler, you gotta go.
But they don't leave.
And of course they don't leave
because they have
extraordinary success,
extraordinary wealth,
extraordinary health,
all of these things,
the things that they
only take for granted
because of our success.
So whatever our political
differences are,
we've got to put them
aside at the moment.
And then I would say, if we
can get some of these wins,
so let's say Youngkin
actually wins in Virginia
and it sends a signal, right?
It sends a signal
across the country.
Holy cow, holy cow,
maybe there's a real
pushback against wokeness.
The system that we have,
the Federalist system,
that these states are supposed
to operate independently,
in some ways it's working
at its highest level
right now, right?
The states are so profoundly
different right now
that in many ways,
it's like being in
different countries.
When I'm in California,
it feels dark and depressing
and everyone's masked.
And you can sorta...
I actually don't leave
my house that often
because there's
just not much to do
and I don't feel like being
around a lot of these people.
But when I do go shopping,
you see people and
they've got the mask
and they kind of
look glossed over.
They don't look like
they're thinking,
they look deeply depressed.
You see this almost everywhere.
I live in Los Angeles,
which is a particular
brand of the craziness.
But in some ways, it shows
you that the system's working,
these people seemingly
want it, right?
Larry Elder ran a
great campaign, I
think, for the recall.
It did not go well, obviously.
I campaigned with Larry,
and the way the
media treated Larry,
the L.A. Times calling him
the blackface of
white supremacy.
I mean, yeah, like stuff that
you truly cannot imagine.
Joe Biden showing up a
day before the recall,
refusing to even say
Larry Elder's name
and calling him a Trump clone,
a man who grew up in
South Central L.A.,
the son of a janitor
came from nothing,
who has made himself
into, I think,
one of the best public thinkers
that we have in the country,
the way they dismissed him
and attacked him
and everything else.
But I mention all that
because California
seems to want it.
They've sort of
made their decision.
We like this. We like
this ever expanding state.
We like the school boards
that have complete
control over us.
We'd rather talk
about gender pronouns
than fixing the streets
or getting the homeless
people off the streets
or the drugs or the
crime that's going up.
We bring in the DA who
ruined San Francisco.
I mean, literally,
San Francisco,
which I was also in San
Francisco a couple weeks ago,
which is a dystopian nightmare.
It looks like "Blade Runner".
It is just an absolute
nightmare. Well, what happened?
The DA of San Francisco
became the DA of Los Angeles.
Bernie backed DA's
name as George Gascon
and now you're allowed
to, in essence,
steal up to, I think, it's
850 or $900 worth of stuff
and they will not prosecute you.
So you can basically
walk into Best Buy
and steal a PlayStation
5 and four games.
But if you steal a fifth game,
then they're gonna get on you.
It is just absolutely
incredible.
But I mention this
because the experiment
is kind of working.
California is getting
what it asked for.
New York is getting
It's funny, as I'm
sure many of you know,
I was off the grid.
I do this August off the grid,
no phone, no news,
nothing, every year.
I've done it for five years.
When I came back this
year on September 1st,
Adam Carolla hosted my show
and he told me
everything that I missed.
And he told me
about Andrew Cuomo,
in essence, being taken out.
And I didn't know who the
Lieutenant Governor was.
I didn't know if it
was a man or a woman.
I knew absolutely
nothing about the person,
but I said to him before
he even told me anything,
I said, "I guarantee
you, whoever it is,
it will be worse."
And congratulations, New
York, it is worse, right?
I mean, they're, yeah.
(crowd clapping)
So that's the point.
The states in many ways
are breaking apart.
Now I wanna keep
this union, right?
We're called the United
States of America.
United is first. We should
keep this thing together.
We need some of that glue.
We've got to do this,
or we'll be in some sort of
perpetual low-grade civil war.
That will not be good.
The challenge on us, I think,
is as the states kind of go
in these different directions
and as a sort of new,
I would say broader,
hopefully conservative
movement comes together,
the real question
will be, well, okay,
if certain places,
let's say, Florida
is I would say the
pinnacle of doing it right,
and Ron DeSantis, I
actually met him last week,
this is a good, decent man
and I hope he will
run for president.
(crowd clapping)
I hope he will
run for president.
And I also think that
whether he does or doesn't,
wherever Trump
fits into all that,
the crop of Republicans coming
up is really, really strong
and good and diverse
in the right sense,
not in the sense of the
word that the left uses.
But as the states go
off in different ways,
the challenge will be, okay,
so if Florida is
gonna do it right,
and Tennessee is
gonna do it right
and Texas is gonna do it right,
well, will the other
guys leave us alone?
And I don't think
the answer is yes.
As a matter of fact, I'm
sure the answer is no.
The more successful that
Florida continues to be,
as it brings in police officers
and EMT people and nurses
that are getting fired for
making personal decisions,
as Florida brings
them in, yeah...
(crowd clapping)
As Florida brings them
in and become stronger
and becomes a state where
the rule of law matters
and basic truth matters
and we're not gonna
teach children neo racism
and the rest of it.
As these states do these things
and I do think hopefully
it will start happening
in Virginia now too
if today goes well,
the other states, they're
not gonna be happy
with that success.
They will not leave that alone.
So I think our next challenge
that we should start
thinking about now
is if you live in
one of these states,
figure out how to
defend that state.
I mean that sort
of intellectually,
but I mean it sort of
physically as well,
figure out how we're
gonna make sure
that the states
are doing it right
are not going to be
under endless assault
from the states that aren't.
And with all that being said,
I do think we can build
something very wide right now.
And the difference is,
again, they are not small.
They are not small, okay?
We talked about some deep
religious stuff last night,
we talked about
abortion last night.
These are real things,
these are important things,
but we gotta save
the country first.
I have no doubt
that every speaker
that you're going to hear
for the rest of today
and that you've heard
over the last couple days
wants to live in
the same country,
wants to live in a country that
has been the great promise.
It is a dream.
It is an extraordinary dream
that this thing is here
and we are on the
precipice of letting it go.
So I think we all
have our work to do.
And most importantly,
and I ended my speech in the
VIP room with this yesterday,
let's go, Brandon.
(crowd clapping)
Thank you, everybody.
Enjoy the rest of the
conference. Thank you, guys.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.